[Music]
foreign
folks welcome back today is the second
in our three-part series on the Netflix
film The Social dilemma the contentious
film today we have Abby Gupta the
founder and principal researcher at the
Montreal AI ethics Institute we had an
incredibly fruity conversation and we
covered many thorny issues I've really
enjoyed the conversation Keith had his
own take on overcoming our weaknesses
and undermining on vulnerabilities we
spoke about the threat landscape and
blind spots we spoke about differential
reality versus universal shaping we
spoke about shared reality incentives
and tools Federated information autonomy
diversity is a metric inclusion is a
strategy how locally aligned Pockets can
stabilize Global diversity making
inclusion easier with tools open
sourcing the algorithms the N plus one
cost of inclusion and we finish off by
talking about the broader impact
statement that we see on many of these
research papers these days so Facebook
put out an official article about this
which is what the social dilemma gets
wrong they said that we should have
conversations about the impact of social
media on our lives but the social
dilemma buries the substance in
sensationalism rather than offer a
nuanced look at technology it gives a
distorted view of how social media
platforms work to create a convenient
scapegoat for what a difficult and
complex societal problems the film's
creators do not include insights from
those currently working in the companies
or any experts that take a different
view to the narrative put forward by
that film they also don't acknowledge
critically or otherwise the efforts
already taken by companies to address
many of the issues they raise instead
they rely on commentary from those who
haven't been on the inside for many
years here are the core points that the
film gets wrong so it talks about
addiction Facebook builds its products
to create value not to be addictive two
you are the product Facebook says that
it's funded by advertising so that it
remains free to people
three the algorithms Facebook's
algorithm is not mad it keeps the
platform relevant and useful for data
Facebook has made improvements across
the company to protect people's privacy
five polarization we take steps to
reduce content that could drive
polarization six elections Facebook has
made Investments to protect the
Integrity of Elections seven
misinformation we fight fake news
misinformation and harmful content using
a Global Network of fact checking
partners so feel free to go and check
out this article the only one of those
seven points which rubs me a little bit
I think is asserting that you are not
the product
clearly you are the product
I think we're just arguing about
semantics here one of the people said in
the film that they're not necessarily
selling you they are selling your
attention and they're selling the
ability to change
your perceptions and change what you pay
attention to that's what they're selling
and it clearly has huge market value and
advertisers are prepared to pay for that
so I think it's a little bit
disingenuous to try and claim that's not
the product or that you're not the
product because clearly it's very
closely related anyway remember to like
comment and subscribe we really love
reading your comments and we had a lot
of fun making this episode remember to
check us out next week when we have Dr
Rebecca roach who's a senior lecturer in
philosophy and ethics at Royal Holloway
University of London I'm super excited
about that episode peace out I do want
to pick up on one specific thing though
so you brought up what I thought was a
truly brilliant quote like one of the
very interesting points made were this
guy said we've been worried all this
time about when AI would overcome our
strengths yeah when we really should
have been worried about when it would
overcome our weaknesses yeah and and
yeah Nick you were kind of like Ah
that's just you can just take one minus
weakness and you're gonna strength or
whatever I think that misses the point
which is that every every individual we
do have sets of strengths and weaknesses
and I think we could Define that
formally if we wanted to like a behavior
that we have greater or lesser degree of
conscious control over or whatnot but I
think it makes this very valid point
that kind of in all our
doomsday AI thinking we've always been
worried about when will they be able to
shoot down all our aircraft carriers
we've got Nano laser beam or something
like that whereas really this is a
bigger problem for us is when is AI
going to allow systems and other people
to just abuse our kind of weaknesses
that have crept into us over millions of
years of evolution to the point where it
just degrades our productivity I think
for the most part that's already
happened right if you look at the
YouTube kids I think it was late 2017 I
believe I forget his name now I forget
his name anyways uh there's this guy who
did a bunch of Investigation in terms of
the kinds of videos that were gaining
popularity on on YouTube kids and and a
lot of them were actually quite
disturbing in terms of the content like
definitely not appropriate for children
but in a very subtle way so they were
psychologically disturbing yet made with
cartoon characters which I think is the
worst kind of disturbing content that
you can make it's like those little evil
babies that you have or the puppets that
have gone evil so it was that kind of
freak key right and certainly that's the
kind of content I think where and this
was one of the guyslow who was in the
social dilemma as well unfortunately
didn't get enough Air Time Tristan
Harris monopolized most of it I don't
know if he funded the movie did he I'm
not sure but it seemed he certainly
seems that way he spoke for the longest
out of everybody
um with all the money he's made off of
human futures
you know oh oh yeah tell me and and you
know what was interesting and I don't
know what do you guys think about this
but it's
it's fascinating that the people that
they've brought on to talk about this
it's when we're talking about it's
almost like they've had a moral
Awakening which is great God bless them
God bless us for having that but
when they talk about oh we didn't know
that this could happen that I I don't
agree with the and and one of the
examples that I wanted to talk about was
today a lot of these folks went through
BJ fogg's Center for persuasive
technology lab
so you got to be kidding me it has it in
its title of the lab that it's about
persuasive technology so where was the
disillusion went there yeah it was
obvious that's what you were you know
signing up to do that's something I'd
like to discuss today is when did they
cross the line because clearly every
technology can have unintended
consequences and and I believe them when
they said that the like button was not
they had no conception that it would
lead to some of the problems that that
it has but at some point they crossed
the line but anyway let's introduce
everyone properly and then we can kick
off into the discussion today we have a
good friend of mine Abby Gupta so Abby
is best described as an incredible force
of nature he is an AI ethics researcher
and he's working on creating ethical
safe and inclusive AI he's the founder
and principal researcher at the Montreal
AI ethics Institute he's a machine
learning engineer at Microsoft and we
were partners in crime at Microsoft for
several years and he's on responsible AI
board in CSE at Microsoft he represented
Canada in the future of work program for
the U.S state department and he earned
his degree in computer science from
McGill University which is the same
place as our friend bengio works now of
course uh we'll link to his website um
after the show as well because he's got
a quite an impressive list of accolades
on his website
but also joining us today is Yannick
Lightspeed Kilcher
we have Alex bazian stenlake and we also
have MIT PhD Dr Keith also Bayesian
Duggar
now
go on Oh no just before we go further
because we had a comment about us
butchering names and I'm not an expert
in pronouncing names Abby how what's the
proper way to pronounce your name for
today yeah no Abby is great that's what
all the people who like me call me Abby
and those who don't call me Abhishek
okay so Abby Abby maybe this changes
during the video
yeah we got in trouble for mispronics
I've known Sachin for for many years now
and I've clearly been saying it his name
wrong the whole time well I think it was
mainly me but that's why it was me too I
looked at the pronunciation and it was
me too anyway
um coming back to the social dilemma so
um there have been some huge concerns
about social media in general and it's
been said that social media games and
deranges our attention Instagram for
example it can learn many things about
you without taking any explicit actions
in the system for example it could learn
your sexual orientation just by
measuring the amount of time that you
look at certain pictures so it could be
concerning from a privacy point of view
some have claimed that social media
might represent the kind of climate
change of culture polluting our social
fabric so should social media be
regulated there were naysayers before
the smoking ban and seat belt
regulations were introduced but now no
one's suggesting we should turn the
clock back who gets to Define what hate
speech is and what is acceptable public
discourse as the film said the current
best proxy for truth is a human click
it's simply not possible to tell
algorithmically if something is true or
not so could social media undermine
democracy is it a good use of our time
or is it paternalistic to dictate what
is and what isn't a good use of our time
is this just a moral Panic is social
media improving Society in some ways
Society is changing fast and perhaps
it's not possible to put the genie back
in the bottle and the road to hell is
paved with good intentions anyway this
is our street talk today and welcome to
the show Abby it's fantastic to have you
on
hey pleasure to be here glad to have a
chance to talk about this uh hopefully
we'll get into uh some maybe corny areas
or maybe not so thorny areas but I think
hopefully we can feel back the sort of
superficial layer that this movie is put
forth I think in a lot of Senses I think
it's done a good job because again folks
like us who work in the industry only
have uh so much of an audience and a
reach in terms of being able to convince
people but something like Netflix and
presumably the people that they brought
on have a larger audience so there are
you know positives of course and want to
make sure that we get that out of the
way unless someone fault us for saying
that well they only said bad things
about the movie and then talk about any
of the positives why don't we
um kick off with your take on on the
film happy
yeah no um I think let me say this
because I think we'll touch on a lot of
aspects uh here one of the things that
caught my attention was a particular
gripe that I've had with a lot of
popular media portrayal of AI systems
which is anthropomorphizing everything
right so again here what is AI being a
person or or rather three people in this
context optimizing for monetization and
engagement and and whatever else my
concern with that is I think it
continues to misinform the public I
understand that it's hard to portray an
algorithm in a way that's probably
visually engaging though I I will say
that there are ways to do it if you look
at the the Stitch fix website right so
they've got a great blog where they
visualize some of the algorithms and how
they operate and how they go about their
data science workflows it's quite
stunning actually and quite accessible
to uh people who maybe aren't well
versed with it I feel it's a cop-out for
them to have an important Nation or to
have people represent those AR systems
because again it's pushing the narrative
that whenever AI is deployed or
portrayed it's it's always in the form
of an embodied intelligence which is the
problem with Terminator and everything
else that all these sort of popular
portrayals whereas
if the truth is a lot more ambient in
the sense that it's basically an add-on
feature in our existing software systems
right there's nothing there's no
flashbang and it's like oh look at this
Genie AI embodied robot thing that's
shown up and it's it it honestly is just
an additional feature that maybe
improves your productivity hopefully uh
at least that's what people claim but
such a starting Miss portrayal on it and
I think that was one of the things that
isn't being talked about enough which I
think uh ought to be discussed though
there are of course many other things
yeah but just a gentle Challenge on that
because um Tristan said that we thought
that AI would overwhelm our strengths
but it undermined our weaknesses in a
way that's what you've said it's not
this anthropomorphic embodied
intelligence it's actually something
quite simple and diffuse but it's still
apparently overcome us
yeah yeah no and I think a part of it is
also when we're talking about a weakness
I think of course they made the point
that our brains haven't evolved to
ingest the the flood of information that
we have the number of connections that
we try to keep up with the kind of
social validation that we get and all of
those things and
and I think I I forget who it was I
think it was nicknamey who uh made that
uh comment where it's it's this
adversarial Dynamic right where on the
one hand you have a system uh where we
have the system that has so much
information about us that's that's sort
of fighting against us to steal our
attention and on the other hand we're
still are in our cave people roots with
our primitive brains they're trying to
fight back of course we're outmatched
there's this interesting point around
the attention economy
that was raised in the film without
discussing are there timing push
notifications you very precisely to
capture your attention
firstly frankly I don't ever remember a
push notification that distracted me in
fact they usually get turned off because
I get sick of having 50 lined up but I
think that sort of Mo that sort of
capturing of the attention economy
missing the point of like where the
threat actually comes from there's more
interesting and more subtle changes of
behavior here and in fact I think it was
you that identified it years and years
ago looking at the way that Gmail auto
complete limits our range of expression
and there's
if you want to talk about like effects
on human culture surely like we should
be paying attention to this sort of
stuff they can you impact some of the I
guess some of the blind spots within the
film using your experience with the
broader ethical challenges of AI yeah
yeah no and that's a great example I
yeah totally uh should have mentioned
that that's great that you brought that
up because this is so there's a bit of
Auto nudging with with those sort of
boxed responses that you get on your
Android or iPhone app but there's also
of course the smart compose right which
uh again subtly nudges you towards
conforming to particular styles on
another note you can think about
examples in terms of how we're altering
our conversation Styles when it comes to
smart home assistance as well life Alexa
doesn't understand what you're saying
you rephrase your conversation until it
gets it right which is the opposite of
what we want is for the technology to
adapt to us and not for us to adopt
adapt to to technology right on a
broader node I think one of the things
and relating it back to the movie that
wasn't really covered and should have
been made a bit more explicit is they
talked about how social validation a lot
of younger teens and folks are deriving
their sort of social validation from
these Quantified metrics that are that
are on there so I'm wondering if it
would have made sense for them to talk
about there was a study that came out
from from the algorithmic watch so it's
an organization based based out of
Europe who analyze how Instagram just by
the way it promotes different kinds of
posts actually nudged people into
showing more skin because that's what
ended up performing better
right so there's there's a reshaping of
sort of cultural norms as well where to
participate in this ecosystem it's not
just the social validation that you're
getting but also your social norms that
are evolving where you taking a fully
clothed picture of yourself on vacation
is not beneficial from a social
validation perspective anymore it's in
fact that you have to show as much sin
as possible because that is what will
you know get engagement will show up
organically for other people to watch
and provide you with validation
but wasn't that always the case like it
doesn't really matter where you show
your vacation pictures if at least like
either more skin is beneficial or more
skin is detrimental to the success of
the picture it doesn't it's not it I get
the point that this is vastly Amplified
and actually modifies social behavior in
a way that you you might not be be aware
of it but I would say yeah and also so
to the general more General point of
this Gmail autocomplete and whatnot of
course you can say it boxes you in it
limits your expressivity but on the
other hand I think what these systems
show us is that we're not so unique
after all like most of us will complete
that email with one of these three
sentences minus plus a few typos and I
mean the entire recommendation system
industry is based on the fact that
humans aren't so different like it's oh
you're one of those people okay so
yeah I just I think the you formulated
it well but it was always the case or do
you see a particular distinction with
the social media systems that wasn't
there like that wasn't
there when you just showed your pictures
to your friends just a tiny add-on to
that Instagram has made this happen more
efficiently and faster but
why does sex sell
why does sharing more skin get more
engagement I think it's culturally
determined to a certain extent because
Alex is in China at the moment when I
went to China they have a very different
culture almost an asexual kind of
infantilizing culture I would imagine
Instagram in China would be quite
different Maybe I'm Wrong I Don't Know
WeChat is a very different world taking
a look at how things spread on WeChat
now obviously there are some people
pulling some levers in the background
there deliberately but for the most part
it's fairly organic if if you have an
idea of a stereotype of what Japan might
be like that's what WeChat feels except
not just photos of girls although that
certainly exists cars and food a hell of
a lot of time it's cars and food you
know Instagram certainly has people
sharing their food but nothing to the
extent of what I've seen here in China
so Abby you've talked a bit about Mis
framing of the movie and so on so if you
were given like the budget and the task
of making this movie making the movie
about what the combination of social
media and AI specifically what are the
dangers of that what would your kind of
focus be what would your story be
so my story I think my story in fact I I
wanted to actually answer one of the
questions that you asked and then I'll
jump into answering uh the question
around how I might have done it
differently so in terms of when you said
what is different in terms of pictures
let's say over showing them in in person
versus now on social media and Tim said
of course it's Amplified to a great
extent there's also that
universalization of these Aesthetics
right so I don't know if you guys had
read this a while ago where all cafes
whether you're in Mumbai or Monaco or
Montreal they all now look the same
they've got that exposed brick those
four plans and the the Addison bulbs and
and what have you right so again there's
that shaping that's happening I think
which is uh
I think it's stealing away the richness
and I'm with the organic that we're
maybe not as unique as we think we are
but I would expect a cafe in Mumbai to
look different from a cafe in Montreal
if I wanted a cafe that looks like a
Montreal Cafe I would go to Montreal and
not to Mumbai but I think there's that
universalization of the aesthetic which
platforms like Instagram have promoted
there's a philosophical thing now
because uh one of the points the film
raises is this differential reality
that
that everyone has the option whether or
not to follow someone on Facebook and to
present their own identity as a kind of
snowflake and even though you can look
at it as being quite conformalized
actually just look at the number of
permutations of things that you may
choose to follow or not it it creates a
very unique reality for everyone
so I'm gonna I'm gonna push back on that
and say do we really have free choice in
in picking the people that we choose to
follow
and and the reason I bring that up is
because you're shown a certain set of
recommendations based on who they think
you're most likely to connect with they
show me someone who's like way outside
of my network I will probably not click
on it not connect with them which harms
their underlying motives
in which case they are actually to a
great extent curtailing the kind of
choices that I have and and just even in
the order of
um a display of the connections that I
should connect with or the friends that
I should connect with probably plays a
role so if someone is fifth down on the
list I'm not as likely to click on them
as the person who is up top so I don't
know if there's probably something to be
said there as well in terms of what kind
of choices we have but another force is
regularizing or chaotic if if you have
10 groups on Facebook that's 2 to the
power of 10 permutations of combinations
and
if you did have a certain permutation
would that reality be very different to
another reality because the question is
it a bit like the butterfly flaps its
wings and you end up there's a storm the
other side of the world or does it not
really matter which combination of
things you follow does it it doesn't
really make any difference
I yeah
I don't know I I think to a certain
extent it does have an impact right in
the sense that if if I were to not click
on a certain set of groups I might not
be shown some of the downstream
recommendations that could have let's
say I was to subscribe to the 5G
spreading the coronavirus conspiracy
thing right and now that they know
that's one thing that I'm interested in
it's opened up this around most
possibilities in terms of everything
else here pizzagate or Flat Earth and
whatever other conspiracy theories but
if I was to not click on that and then
of course there's a whole other pathway
in terms of the groups that I would be
shown and then of course that has a
cascading effect the further down we go
right because I now become a part of
those communities and and that starts to
become my world you almost get
indoctrinated depending on also a little
bit your sort of Savvy with digital and
and media this idea pushes back on on
what Yannick was saying earlier about
the success of the recommender system
industry yes it's a successful industry
but how much of this is Runaway feedback
loops that no one's really watching and
people have only become aware of in the
last couple of years these this idea of
the differentiation of realities how
much of that is just we've got these
recommender systems that can drive a
sufficient critical mass of people
towards given narratives how much of it
actually is
a diffusion of points of view and how
much of its runaway feedback feedback
affects locking people into kind of like
epistemic bubbles would be one way of
thinking it absolutely I'm not ever
debating that I completely agree with
that point I was just like just the fact
that recommender systems work and work
in non-arbitrary ways it's obvious
because people aren't that unique not
everyone is like duper unique you are
actually similar to other people and I
think that the solution and I've said
this on the last segment is to find a
way to monetize breaking out of the
recommender system and this is the same
way the solution to misinformation and
whatnot is to be to find a way to
monetize truth and I'm a fan of crypto
projects like auger and betting markets
where I think the only way you're going
to get there is through money honestly
like through or some sort of other
Capital like social reputation but money
I feel is the is the big deal here and
the solution to all of this probably
also the source of all of it so yeah I'm
gonna agree with Yannick there which is
that when you can project things down to
the space of money becomes a much more
sort of reliable measure the other thing
to do and this is this philosophy of
make the right thing easy to do which is
if we believe that there's a social good
for example in exposing people to
anti-beliefs things opposite of what
they currently believe why couldn't a
search engine like Google for example
just have two columns of display there
like here's all the things that you
agree with and then for each one of
these links we're also presenting you
with and maybe it's an optional thing I
click Like Show anti-beliefs and it
shows me the top links that people on
the other side of the Viewpoint we might
find that if that tool set was available
that people would engage with it we
don't know maybe we would find that
30 percent of the time people go for the
cognitive dissonance and go to engage
things that they don't like the people
that say yeah I listen to Rush Limbaugh
I hate them but I just want to see all
the hear all the Nutty stuff that the
other side is thinking but we have to
give that tool set to them we have to
give people the options rather than only
automatically funneling them down
further and further crystallization of
their current beliefs I give that all of
30 minutes before some Public Relation
firm weaponizes it
that's okay I don't look look I'm one of
those when it comes to say Free Speech
I'm one of those people that bleed the
antidote to free speech is more free
speech and the antidote to to messy
technology is more technology and and so
okay fine like somebody figures out how
to weaponize it we can figure out how to
create defenses against it in clever
ways but I think the option is just more
freedom more availability more tools uh
more transparency yeah rather than more
constraints more hidden features more
you know yeah 100 yeah no and and yeah
I'm with you on that and I think there
have been demonstrations where you know
providing people with those tool sets
actually does help nudge their behaviors
into seemingly being a little more
self-reflective right for example they
Limited in India to prevent the spread
of misinformation on WhatsApp if they
limited the number of people that you
can forward the messages to at a time
and that's actually helped in terms of
now people instead of mass forwarding a
message to all the groups that you're a
part of you have to think for a second
before making that choice so it's almost
in a sense analogy but it's a little bit
like the character constraints on
Twitter where now you have to be with me
and you have to be careful in terms of
what you can be verbose you have to pick
what you're saying of course you can you
know thread it out and do whatever but
uh for the purpose of one tweet of
course that that is something that's
possible yeah
I wanted to bring it back to one other
thing Yannick said and for the listeners
he had to drop early he that's why he's
gone he's not offended at anything he
said but he mentioned okay say this auto
complete like it's whatever system is
recommending completions of the sentence
I'm writing and we're worried that it's
going to constrain our freedom the way I
look at that is I look positively at the
possibilities of that new world so if
actually an AI gets good enough to
understand and predict what I want to
say that I only have to tweak 20 of the
email instead of writing out a hundred
percent of the email I don't see a
problem with that because I like to just
in my mind do these thought experiments
of the ultra extreme con end of that
that path if you will and it makes me
think of the series of science fiction
novels by Ian Banks called the culture
series or we're in there it's this hyper
intelligence and basically everything is
done for people they they want for
nothing and so then at that point
everybody's just trying to find ways to
entertain themselves and enjoy life
because everything's taking care of them
I don't necessarily think that's a bad
outcome what happens in these sort of
social like in the social media dilemma
yes if we have a teenager who's spending
an inordinate amount of their time
comparing themselves to Impossible
standards and worrying about every like
and whatever then that's a damaging kind
of activity right because it's harming
their psychology it's making them more
likely to hurt them cells it's sucking
up all their their time that they should
be spending learning maybe the solution
there is just better tools to make sure
they they only spend a fraction of their
time on that like one hour a day and
this is where like the tool set that for
example is available to parents needs
significant Improvement because for
example Apple okay on the iPhone they
have these parental controls and screen
time controls and everything one it's a
pain to set them up two there's like
loopholes in there that the kids find
and you have to constantly go watch
YouTube videos and websites to make sure
you're catching all those and plugging
them up there's even applications that
completely ignore them it's like one of
the the games my son loves to play
however they've just totally gotten away
with disregarding the screen time 100
right so then I got to go to my Wi-Fi
network and and have it shut down at a
certain time of the day in other words
and I'm a technology guy so I can do all
this stuff but for a lot of parents it's
beyond their k capabilities they can't
keep up with all this so we need better
tools we need more tooling better tools
easier to understand tools to make the
right thing easier to do
so you're saying it's fundamentally a
policy plus technology problem
yeah it's an individual Choice including
the individual choice of parents to
figure out how they think their kids
should be regulated plus the tooling
necessary to implement those those
choices even things like me personally
for example if there was a if there was
an app that really could prevent me from
overusing social media or something I
might install that but the way they are
right now they have loopholes and since
I know the loopholes I'm going to use
the loopholes so I think we just need
much better tooling and ideas around how
to regulate our behaviors can we Define
what constitutes pathological usage
because in the introduction I talked
about this paternalistic culture where
we assume that gamblers are always
wasting their time why would they want
to
throw away their money like that and
it's the same thing with people who take
drugs recreationally and even in those
cohorts you can break it up so there's
roughly 10 percent of people that
clearly have a pathology they develop an
addiction which has certain
characteristics like you you hide your
usage from other people when you have a
kind of withdrawal and so on but there's
also a long tail isn't there there's a
middle tier of usage where one might say
that it's not a good use of your time
but yeah I have the right to say that so
I'm much more open personally about I
don't think gambling is a waste of time
I think if it dominates a person's life
to the point where it's damaging their
health and psychology and all that then
it's a problem I don't think
I think a lots of drugs shouldn't be
illegal I think actually for example we
legalized drugs say in the United States
but required that they passed the same
degree of approval that medications do
in other words they have to demonstrate
efficaciousness safety Etc that's
probably a better world if you don't get
along with your in-laws and they're
coming over for a visit who cares if you
go to the pharmacy and pick up a little
purple pill that helps you get through
the evening right if it's not going to
harm you and kill you and so if we open
this up and give people the freedom and
choice and make it safer and make it
easier for them to do the right things
to moderate their behavior to not become
addicted that's a better approach but
sure there is a line right but just on
that because addiction is a symptom
of a toxic environment so a lot of
people they get addicted to for example
if I gave you a load of heroin tomorrow
even if you took it you wouldn't get it
it's quite difficult to get addicted to
heroin people get addicted to it because
they have life syndrome and they
want to reduce attention to their
stresses and people get addicted to
gambling for similar reasons but with um
Facebook it's a little bit more esoteric
right it's the thing is it a bad thing
for people to watch videos of dogs it
might be soothing for people just to
temporarily escape from their work
environment and just to immerse
themselves in the world of puppy videos
I was literally commenting to my family
in the family group chat today SpongeBob
SquarePants since I don't touch drugs I
haven't even touched weed since I was a
kid but SpongeBob SquarePants videos man
it's I'm there
in the sense that they can offer free
when you're going through stress and of
course the one point that I liked that
you made was around having clear
information embedded information in
terms of the efficaciousness in terms of
the safety so ultimately I think
and give me some rope here but I think
what we're trying to say is that we need
to have sufficient transparency and
information so that people are able to
make an informed choice and I think
that's what's missing is in an
environment like Facebook we don't have
uh an informed decision-making process
because we think it's benign and I I
think it was I I forget who's there were
two children in the video that they
showed that there was a brother and a
sister so there was that dramatization
part but there was one of the one of the
speakers children and and they when they
were asked how much time they spend they
were they underestimated it because they
didn't know and I think that's where the
problem is that which also relates to
your point around Tooling in making that
a lot more upfront making that a lot
more transparent and and effective
because that's also that's right partly
what's lacking is the efficaciousness
there I'm interested to know where you
draw the line though because yeah you
could argue that you know then
philosophy there's the The Experience
machine which is imagine you could go
into virtual reality and just live in
the perfect world everything was
wonderful and you wouldn't want to leave
and Facebook is about as close to that
as you could possibly imagine when you
go in there as I said it even the guy
yesterday we had Andy Smith on the
security consultant and he said he was
really careful he doesn't give away
anything about himself when he uses
social media but of course that's
rubbish even the amount of time you
spend looking at every piece of
information they're profiling you and
they're showing you a reality just for
you and you get drawn in and the whole
purpose of this technology is to be
persuasive and to derange your attention
and manipulate you so it do we
philosophically is this a binary is this
just a bad thing or is there a line we
can draw on susceptibility
can I open this question up a little bit
more because I know Abby has done a lot
of work like a lot of Consulting work
with companies and governments on like
how to tackle these challenges that come
up can we kind of broadened this just
beyond the the range of the individual
and start to talk about like how does
how do the broad divisions in society
how should they respond to this what
sort of action should they be taking
what sort of action should they be
avoiding
yeah no and so it's an interesting point
in the sense that I see the point around
us or US I say some group being
paternalistic and and prescribing to
others what is good or what is bad and I
think
it boils down to self-determination for
that group and I would say what happens
at the individual level also probably
to a certain extent scales to a group
level as well where if you're offering a
sufficient amount of information for
them to choose whether something aligns
with their culture with their contacts
with their values and allows them more
importantly empowers them to make that
choice I think that's what's important
because it's also useless if I tell you
that hey this is all these are all the
ways that you're being manipulated and
does it conform with your values or not
but I don't give you any power to
actually change any of that that also is
useless so I think there's that second
piece which is do are we empowering them
to be able to make that change and often
that piece gets ignored which is also my
gripe and I want to quickly touch back
on the question that Yannick had asked
and I haven't forgotten about how I
would reuse what I think was partially a
waste of time in the movie how they went
about it was to not talk sufficiently
about the potential Solutions blocking
all your notifications isn't the
solution
like it's it's it's a Band-Aid on a dam
that's broken like the band is going to
do nothing it had this had they taken
each of the scenarios and actually
walked through what some of the policy
and Technical instruments can be so
let's say we're talking about the the
online to offline violence that happened
in in India in Myanmar let's talk about
what some of the policy changes were
that were enacted after that what was
the effect what was the effectiveness of
those policy measures what were some of
the technological measures that were put
in place were they effective were they
not effective and I think that would
have been much more realistic you could
have cut out all that dramatization part
uh honestly if you ask me and I've
replaced it drop and replace it with
with Solutions because that's what's
missing and again to your point Alex in
terms of when I speak with governments
and companies and all of this
everybody is great at identifying
problems right which we we love to do
that of course it's fun to point out
problems but let's also try and move
towards Solutions and which has been an
issue in this space as well in this
space of AI ethics where
um everybody loves to identify problems
in terms of privacy in terms of bias and
fairness and misinformation and when you
start to ask the hard questions about
what are some potential Solutions then
it's so well we haven't really given it
that much thought something isn't that
the point on on that because in Myanmar
I think they had four local moderators
that spoke the language and the the
platform that they have the way that
Facebook is monetized is anyone can go
on the platform and they can promote
content
so that's exactly what happened and of
course this can undermine democracy and
and cause all sorts of problems
so there's a fundamental between their
revenue model
and how it's being used
I think when we say things like it
undermines democracy I mean you know
does it yeah at the end of the day if
people are voting it's always been the
case that say charismatic well-spoken
people persuade other people to do what
they want them to do and and to a large
extent people uh have their opinions
based on their friends their families
where they grew up their you know the
the narratives that they're being told
and whatnot so I don't I don't know that
there's really anything new here and I
think a lot of times when we say it's
undermining democracy it's really just
that whatever the outcome was we didn't
like and therefore let's say that it's
undermining something that everybody
cares about like democracy but I just
want to pull back for a second just to
the the point that Abby raised about
again the transparency the availability
of accurate information and tooling to
empower people to make their own
informed decisions I think that's the
route that we have to go which is it's
just distributed control idea provide
make sure that we provide getting good
information and by the way as open and
transparent information as we can I
don't want some monolithic government
deciding what's true and what's false
like that's sort of an absurd situation
to be in but just providing people the
tooling and the knowledge the
information they need to come to inform
decisions and then just let the chips
fall where they fall it's like if we if
we've told you the bad things that can
happen if you become addicted to social
media giving you the information giving
you Alternatives giving you tooling to
control them at the end of the day if
you're neural net that you were born
with and that you grew over time decides
to just ignore all that and get addicted
that's life like we can't control
everybody we can't micromanage every
autonomous you know entity I these human
beings walking around I'm quite
persuaded by the case notion of having a
Federated approach to social media but
it we are in the age of globalization
and it is in a way it is a monolithic
application that everyone logs into and
one of the interesting sticking points
here is the the relative Notions of
knowledge and values and Truth
depending on where you are in the
political Spectrum you might argue that
one of those three things is absolute or
constructed in some way so how do you
how does that fit into the Paradigm of
potentially having a Federated social
media
Federation is the only way to allow that
which is just look if a bunch of people
want to believe that that there's no
that your genes don't influence you
whatsoever but it's all environment and
culturally constructed fine we also need
to have a space where people that want
to believe differently can believe
differently and they're not allowed to
silence each other that again the
antidote to one side's free speech is
more free speech from the other side so
it's that Federated system and when
governments seek to do regulations I
think they need to do so
they need to create regulations that are
very incremental very very simple very
flexible just to create this kind of
fair open transparent sort of space like
for example suppose that a regular came
along and said okay fine Google you go
ahead and keep providing targeted
searches to everybody but you have to
have a button on the page that's default
search or something that I can click on
and it doesn't use my personal
information and every single person
viewing that search sees the exact same
results right let's see the very Target
though isn't it
but again minus the tracking right but
again so what I'm saying is forcing the
platforms that that are doing tracking
to provide an easy way for people to
choose to not be exposed to that within
the platform of their choice like that's
the kind of Regulation Ultra simple easy
for Google to do like I don't care what
they come back with this is like one
hour of coding you know maximum to
provide this this capability okay and
yet it empowers people to at least see
the scary other side that you know maybe
doesn't agree precisely with my opinions
I just have a quick point on that
because one of the reasons I was arguing
that a Federated system might be
dangerous is because we have this kind
of differential Consciousness now
everyone sees a different world when
they log into Facebook and there's been
a huge uptick in post-modernism in the
last 10 years or so and there are people
out there that think that mathematics is
a is a meta narrative it's a social
construct and two plus two only equals
four in the western world and it's just
it's something that we've created and
that's okay that's okay are you saying
that those people should be allowed to
construct that reality when they look
into social media I'm saying they should
be allowed to construct that they should
be allowed to believe that they should
be allowed to test their ideas in
reality they shouldn't be allowed to
suppress and cancel people that disagree
with them and we as a society may decide
that it's also a good thing that they
have easy tools to go see the other side
like buttons that they can click to at
least show them what other people are up
to and thinking
I came up through the social sciences
math was not part of my formal education
and it's amazing how intimidate or how
often people will discourage or
disparage these things
simply because they think oh I can't
understand it or my interpretation is
they because they can't understand it
they're inclined to dismiss it
it's much harder to admit fault and to
move through this but when you sit down
with someone you actually walk them
through what everything means people
change their opinions on this it just
takes that kind of moment of listening
right like this idea of a shattering of
narratives is completely okay
so long as people are willing to sit
down and listen to one another and
that's the Crux of the issue how do you
fix that when there's so much political
power there's so much advantage to be
gained in maintaining that hostility
this is a great system but I don't see
it working let me just make one really
quick comment which is number one most
important criteria is that people can't
silence other people a second possibly
important criteria is that we may want
to encourage people to listen to others
but we absolutely can't allow people to
silence people that disagree with them
mm-hmm no and and so actually to build
build on your point what
so if if we go back to days when
communities were simple where travel
wasn't possible to be far off lands and
and everything right if you had a view
that was potentially misinformed let's
say two plus two is five let's say you
had a community of people around you who
could potentially act as a you know sort
of self-correcting mechanism right where
to to Alex's point someone would sit
down with it and then talk you through
their reasoning and hopefully get you to
change your mind that your two plus two
is not five right and I'll caveat that
by saying that of course because we were
not exposed to other parts of the world
we might hold views that are actually
just wrong as a community and and that
couldn't be broken open right that I
admit but what's changed now compared to
this scenario is that you can always
find
self-confirming evidence for whatever
Niche no matter how Niche your view is
you can probably find a subreddit for it
or as you know tiny Twitter Community
that's probably gonna align with what
you're saying is going to support what
you're saying is going to show you more
evidence to to make you you know Harden
your beliefs and I think that's the
problem where we as people saying We
it's become it's becoming increasingly
difficult for you to break out of those
bubbles because maybe we don't have the
tooling maybe we don't have enough
willpower I don't know there's a lot of
problems there and and to the point on
you know Dr go being an alternative
whether it's Google Minus I guess the
personalization how many people know of
Draco that's why I'm saying it needs to
be a potential regulation and I'm not
saying this one but a potential one
could just be that if you're a search
engine you have to provide this this
experience as a little button that's
larger than one pixel that people can
click on if they want to and so I often
make the analogy that the the internet
has become this Fortress of echo
Chambers where everybody walks in there
goes down a long hallway finds the door
that leads to the dungeon that has all
the people that believe the exact
precise same set of things that they
believe they go in there and they never
come out again and maybe it's a good
idea that we build some little
connecting hallways there and make it
easy for people to get exposed to some
of the other dungeons yeah it's a bit
like in Star Trek Voyager when they had
the Borg had the the Subspace Network so
they could travel around the Galaxy
because again there is an interesting
philosophical point about do we have an
infinitely fractured reality or you
could imagine the space of all humans as
being in a room and in one part of the
room you might have LGBT people and
another you know and you can cluster it
and you can show people well
topologically here's where you are
because one of the reasons we spoke
about the kind of package deal concept
that at the moment you can if you join a
conspiracy theory group like the 5G then
you tend to get the package deal so then
they'll recommend to you that you should
be an anti-vaxxer as well and you should
do this that and the other but there
should be an opportunity to visualize
where you are inside that room and give
you some Subspace wormholes to escape
from where you are if you want to so
here's a here's a problem right now
we're recognizing that there's a
diversity of viewpoints and that we
should Inc we should absolutely not
silence these viewpoints that's right we
understand that there are some
similarities there but within those
groups those similarities like we go
from social psychology that people are
going to differentiate themselves
they're going to find the they're going
to focus on the points of difference
rather than the the similarities
and then there's this idea in AI ethics
and and I kind of want to turn this
across to Abby of representativeness and
ensuring that they're like any
discussion particularly concerning bias
is very inclusive and we try to engage
with all relevant stakeholders how do we
marry this problem just seems like a
wicked policy problem with no way out
it's you're damned if you do or you're
damned if you don't is there a solution
there
so you know I think as a starting point
when we're talking about Representatives
I think there's also this sort of
related problem of of these slow
Gatekeepers and the four Gatekeepers are
these let's say individuals or
organizations that claim to represent a
particular group but they really don't
and a huge problem in the field right
now when you're talking about you know
how it's such a wicked problem is
how do we reach those people whom we
should be speaking with who actually
have the lived experiences so that we
can Surface whatever their culture their
value their Norms are so that we can
incorporate that into whatever Vision
making we have to do and the the problem
right now and this is uh this has been a
an ongoing Topic at The Institute where
we've been fascinated by how the space
itself of AI Ethics in particular has
been monopolized by a few voices has
been monopolized by a few voices that
are eating up the floor space the air
time they're pushing the very voices
that they claim to represent that they
claim to want to empower to the fringes
out of the spotlight and what was
interesting in terms of that discussion
was as some of these people who are are
meant to you know represent the voices
of the people who are traditionally
marginalized to talk about let's say
advice and fairness issues
they all end up suffering from the same
problem of the replication of the power
structures which is as you start to
become more famous or you start to get
more speaking requests or whatever else
it is you tend to aggregate that within
your own uh interests or whatever
to the exclusion of very people that you
were supposed to help out in the first
place the your your own very in group
that you were supposed to help but you
end up this was Maria Farrell's big
criticism of the social dilemma the
so-called prodigal Tech Pro and she said
and they're all men and for those of you
who aren't out there that don't know
this story basically Maria Farrell says
there are fantastic ethical Advocates
researchers out there
sorry II ethics Advocates researchers
Etc but they get no air time because
these people that are quite well funded
that put forward middle of the road
solutions that don't actually solve the
problem eat up all the airtime and get
these great big budgets I I want to
challenge you on this concept of a lived
experience
and and we've just been talking as well
about how the guys on the film were men
and well funded and so on but I'm just a
little bit worried about that because
one thing one thing I'm a little bit
allergic to is is this idea of a group
categorization being the single most
defining thing about you and I resent
the idea that because I'm a white male
that it disentitles me to talk about
certain things the problem with the
lived experience is that
you could say anything you could say
because I'm a category XYZ I've had this
experience and it's disprovable so is
that almost a debasing of the way that
we think about ethics before we go down
that very deep rabbit hole before we go
down there let me just give my
perspective on something because it may
actually address your concern like that
which is because where I work uh
diversity inclusion a very high priority
undergone quite a bit of training over
it or on it over the last few years and
what I've come to realize actually is
that
diversity is a metric
inclusion is a strategy
right and if we if we did perfect
inclusion if we were perfect at
inclusion
whatever diversity results from that is
the ideal diversity
and it may not exactly reflect the exact
combinatorial demographics of the
population in any particular area
because diversity is itself diverse
you know so people do have different
experiences growing up different
cultural experiences as a result of that
as a result of who they are they'll have
different interests right they'll have
different areas of expertise different
skill sets Etc so we can't expect that
on every possible imaginable dimension
in every niche in life the population is
going to precisely reflect the
population and that Niche there has to
be variation or we're in fact denying
the relevance of diversity at all right
so what I found is that a hyper focus on
inclusion okay and that includes
Outreach as well okay a community is not
being represented and and something in
which we believe they have a stake we
should devote resources into Outreach
there going out asking like hey are you
guys interested in participating this do
you want to be part of the conversation
we'd love to have you you know so for
example if coding is dominated by a
particular group Outreach to all the
other groups make sure that there are no
barriers to members from that group
being included so just a hyper hyper
hyper focus on getting inclusion perfect
I think is is our way forward and then
to use diversity as a guide for where or
lack of diversity say as a guide for
maybe where we're falling down or where
there's more resources that need to be
invested but after we've done that
examination and that research and
perfected inclusion it's okay if it
doesn't exactly reflect the population
right metrics not targets yeah maybe
maybe I'll I'll chime in with one thing
to build on Keith's point in terms of
inclusion being the the go-to strategy
in terms of achieving some of the
outcomes that we do want to as a society
there's also there's there's this sort
of external facing aspect of inclusion
but then there's also the internal
facing aspect of inclusion which is
making sure that the people that we do
actually bring in through this now
enhanced inclusion process to actually
feel welcome so that they don't leave
because you you do often have that
people enter the feel but then they exit
because they're uncomfortable because of
just so many reasons and I think that
also is something that that needs to be
practiced and like made a priority and
things like of course training things
like better understanding of the
different sort of perspectives that
people are coming from different even
maybe educational experiences it's
almost like don't fault someone for
using uh emacs if you're a grim guide or
the other way around to give you a silly
analogy there but that's that
understanding and tolerance I think yeah
tolerance really is the word or maybe
it's the wrong word we're not really
tolerating anything it's just being open
because I think tolerating as a negative
connotation for example the commented
the commenter that brought up that and I
know I did mispronouncing
um uh sachin's name right and I hope I
said it correctly there I watch videos I
tried that's an example of where let's
suppose
your Southeast Asian from India and you
join a company that just happens to be
mostly people from the United States and
they're always mispronouncing your name
and they don't even care like they're
not even trying actually to learn how to
pronounce your name right that can be
kind of an exclusionary sort of behavior
because you feel man every day I come in
here nobody's even bothering to learn my
name you know it's it's awareness of all
that kind of stuff which again is about
inclusion that we need to to be more
focused on and I welcome like I love the
training that I get and thinking about
these things for example I always tried
to make sure that in a meeting if
somebody was quiet or not saying much I
would try to reach out to them hey John
did you want to comment on this however
then I learned that some people that can
be put on the spot like that may
actually make them feel uncomfortable so
a little change of tactic was instead of
calling them out in the meeting I would
message them right and say hey John do
you have any you know if you want to add
any comments please speak up or let me
know I can introduce you learning about
all these little tactics for inclusion
very very helpful and I'd love to see
more of that just on that though if you
include one person you exclude another
person and if we have a thought
experiment here imagine if Facebook
didn't have the recommendation algorithm
imagine if it was completely random and
when you saw information on your feed
you it just stratified across every
possible interest and characteristic
because what happens at the moment is
it's about convergence versus Divergence
so Facebook will it has a kind of
convergent behavior and groups of people
will form bases of Attraction and you'll
get clusters of knowledge and thought
and so on if you have the complete
opposite which is pure Divergence then
you'll create some kind of a monoculture
which doesn't really have any defining
characteristics at all and presumably we
don't want that either so where do we
draw the line
but it's something that we don't want
let me just put a kind of visual on that
so we can think about it is that and
again I I live in the United States so
that's why I'm using these examples here
I'm not trying to be U.S Centric I just
don't have enough knowledge to comment
elsewhere in the United States for
example lots of ethnic groups
self-segregate into particular
neighborhoods like for example you've
heard like Chinatown in my view like
some of that is good right because
having a lot of people nearby each other
with the same culture helps them to
maintain that you know they can have a
store that has a culturally appropriate
food and they can get the things that
they're familiar with they have
neighbors that share the culture they
can group together to build a temple
down the road and whatnot so some degree
of kind of of alignment geographically
helps them to maintain their diversity
right if we just spread everybody all
around and had every square mile had the
exact same combination of demographics I
think we would lose actually a lot of
that diversity so the United States
actually isn't a Melting Pot it's a
tossed salad there's all little bits and
pieces everywhere and for me that's a
good thing it's what helps us maintain
that diversity yeah another example of
that is there's this concept of cultural
appropriation which means hypothetically
if I was to wear a sombrero that would
be cultural appropriation but but in a
way diversity is cultural appropriation
because I'm I'm selecting loads of
different folks to work in my group and
what happens is things either converge
or diverge it's just it's a mathematical
reality so you take a diverse group of
people and you make them work together
and what happens is you take a kind of
five point average all of those folks
will converge in the middle and
characteristics of all of their
knowledge and and values will be
combined into one so isn't that just a
form of cultural appropriation so Tim
you're saying that so if we were to have
a team of of people that was let's say
diverse along some axes let's say and
and they formed you sort of five
clusters that they would all converge to
a center to which at which point they
would lose their diversity is that
that's my hypothesis I think there's
this concept of group think there there
are many biases we have like social
proof for example we look at the
decisions of others to and for my own
decisions and I I honestly believe that
we're always moving and we're strongly
influenced by our environment and our
peer group and you you do get this
convergence and surely that would happen
eventually
DNA has this very interesting property
at least the genetic system of life on
Earth has this kind of interesting
property that it actually
maintains digitally the variety of
information but in a state like absent
any outside influences it maintains that
information
stably over time so for example if you
have a diversity of hair color black
blonde red Brown whatever
actually that population will keep that
exact same diversity over the course of
time forever it will always have five
percent redheads 20 blonde whatever the
percentages are they'll stay stable and
you'll see these you'll see this variety
continue to pop up over time just
because of the kind of digital nature of
the genetic code yeah go ahead I'd like
you to to give me some intuition why is
does that mean that it's not a heritable
trait it's actually a consistent
mutation no it's heritable but it's
decomposed into Gene like and I'm going
to simplify a lot of things here so
anybody out there if you jump on me on
the comments understand we're trying to
like keep things flowing in a simple way
here but let's just suppose every trade
is represented by genes okay and there's
one or more uh versions of that Gene
there can be a version a b c for example
those versions are stable and again
absent mutation absent selection they
never change if some point I could write
this down on a whiteboard and you can
see that the this there's a polynomial
that kind of shows you that the
frequencies of these alleles stay the
same and therefore over time you can get
all the different combinations of those
alleles so you wind up keeping
blonde people and brown-haired people
and red-haired people and everything
else you maintain all those combinations
because the genes themselves are digital
and stable but they occur in different
combinations but surely we're
overlooking mutations at this point
because yeah yeah yeah naturally is very
recessive and only kind of shows up
because there's this a sub-population
with a mutation that only shows up in
small relatively isolated areas of the
Earth yeah so I said overlooking
mutation and selective pressure because
if you have selective pressure then it
can change these balances but the point
I'm making there is that it's possible
to maintain variety
but in order to do that you have to have
a component of that variety that's
stable so like the gene is stable for
example just having these populations
like a Chinatown or a an area of town
that's highly Indian for example
represents a stable Gene that can
continue to produce this variation and
maintain this diversity over time and
sending out branches that can float off
into the larger population and spread
that diversity a quick point so now it
depends what you mean by because your
point is there are a lot of Behavioral
traits which are biologically determined
and changes in your biology can produce
a whole bunch of different physical and
behavioral changes but what we're
talking about are almost a level of
abstraction on top of that I think that
there is there's our culture and our
language and so on and this is almost a
form of externalized behavior or
knowledge I know I agree with you I'm
just saying I'm saying that the same
mathematics can apply to that which is
it if you can maintain if you have some
degree of
alignment right you can maintain that
diversity
over time while at the same time still
allowing mixtures of that diversity to
occur elsewhere it's just you have to
keep these Pockets around to maintain
that or or what you said will happen
which is they'll just muddle together
and converge into kind of like a a gray
soup or something but you're making the
argument just forget about genetics for
a minute that the same applies in some
way to our culture and our language I am
even if you have a group of people
together for a significant amount of
time the diversity will be maintained
yeah as long as they keep as long as
they keep Pockets so that so you have to
maintain these Pockets which are the
gene itself has to be maintained
somewhere right it has to be maintained
somewhere but just on that science for
example is a form of externalized
intelligence it's a collective and we
were talking on LinkedIn the other day
we said that science advances one
funeral at a time and there's incredible
convergent Behavior not least triggered
by the when you have reviews on papers
they all have to be accepts and I think
I was making the comment I stole this
from Kenneth Stanley by the way Kenneth
is coming on I'll show in a few weeks
time he made the argument that it should
be maximum disagreement not maximum
agreement so it seems to me that there
are so many mechanisms when you have
groups of people that cause convergent
not Divergent behave rooting this back
into uh ethics of AI and these broader
sort of power structures this idea of
isolated pockets it works out until you
introduce things like Social Power
structures and the wildly different
experiences people have growing up
within these communities
a friend of mine he's he's he's an
African from America not
African-American but grew up with many
of the same social problems and made the
same fears and I remember hanging out
with him one day back in Australia and
I'd I'd had a couple of cops heavily
armored cops knock on my door that day
because they were looking for someone
that used to live there and they meet me
and they were very confused and I was
very confused so invited them into my
house and had a glass of water and Sid
tried to figure out what was going on
and turns out this other person had
moved or whatever I'm recounting this to
my friend and he's looking at me with
eyes like sources and he's you invited
them into your house there is no way in
hell I'd ever do that and it didn't even
cross my mind to be nervous in that
situation it's just like oh this is
weird come on in have a glass of water
it's fine he's laughing at me this this
white boy letting the cops into his
house Etc so like
interacting with those Social Power
structures
like people will con people will tend to
converge because moving towards those
power structures
or rather moving away from them carries
real costs maintaining an identity
carries real costs and often it's
enforced right like the the
America's not exactly like Australia is
not a model for race relations either
but I think we need to be very careful
how we think about this because these
broader structures that can influence
things do completely change people's
relationships uh even between one
another and so we do need to take into
account these different perspectives
because they're just as valid we can't
just dismiss it and say they're lacking
evidence statistically it's all the same
statistically cops Rock up the house is
case of mistaken identity they were
looking for a guy from Brazil like they
weren't going to mistake my friend for
him either but two people same situation
radically different responses because
they're this broader context really does
matter and introducing this context can
help us to spot things that otherwise
would miss
and I think Alex to your point that's
exactly what the benefit of having that
sort of diversity on the team is right
is that if we were to talk about that
you inviting the cops in it is not
absolutely occur to you at all but that
would be something that your you know a
friend would have pointed out right away
if this was some other context based on
your differences and experience they
would be like hey we're designing this
product this thing doesn't work you know
let me give you the example of and uh so
it's a pretty famous one where you have
that soap dispenser where you put your
hand underneath it and it only works for
light skin uh guess what all the testers
on the team had light skin and they were
like every time I put my hand it it it
works out so nothing wrong there good to
go let's ship it out and and then lo and
behold a dark person uh a person with
the dark skin puts their hand and
nothing gets dispensed so it's covering
each other's blind spots I think that's
the benefit and
I don't know if it leads to a
convergence as as stem was you know
saying maybe it does but to Keith's
point I think if if we continue to
maintain at least a portion of our
identities be that through other
mechanisms that are external to that
group where you're creating that
diversity in a single setting I I think
you would still continue to reap the
benefits without many of the sort of
negative consequences did we make a
distinction though because you gave the
example of the hand sanitizer not
recognizing dark colored skin then there
is the gender Shades paper uh talking
about the differences in predictive
accuracy on facial recognition systems
and those are egregious of course they
should work for everyone that's just a
simple
um case of fairness but the problem is
this line of reasoning can just go one
step further and one step further so the
next step is to say that all of the
systems uh of power in our society have
been inadvertent recently not designed
as the wrong word but they've been
constructed in a way to systematically
oppress people of certain
categorizations
and at that point then it becomes quite
difficult to to disprove or to reason
about that how do you take that on
experience well there's always
extremes you know and the Pendulum
always swings and there's always a line
at some point where where it starts to
become nonsensical like
you know I'm sorry folks out there
mathematics is not racist right like
arithmetic
is not racist you know uh symbolic
integration
isn't racist right but on the other hand
Court stenographers in the United States
have shown that and this applies by the
way to both black and white Court
sonographers
have I have shown far greater errors in
typing up the spoken words of uh black
defendants and people giving testimony
in court right so there's some type
linguistic relationship there and I
think what has to happen is we have to
be like always on the lookout for things
like that this happens the thing with
the hands you know that happens actually
in even more severe cases in the medical
field where they don't do a good job
with the randomized kind of sampling of
the population and we end up with
medications that work well for men and
not women or that work well for
Caucasians and don't work well for
blacks so we've got to be aware of of
where there are
you know and almost obsessively you know
looking around for for cases where that
that might arise but then if we go so
far as to start saying yeah the
scientific method is racist I mean I'm
sorry those folks that believe that
you can continue believing that I'm not
going to try and stop you from from
saying that you don't try to stop me
from saying that you're a little nuts
and will agree to disagree and you try
to apply your theories to the real world
and we'll try to apply ours and
eventually natural selection will figure
out whose ideas are are scientifically
correct so I don't think anyone's
suggesting that these systems were
designed to be tyrannical
but the problem is it's about the
consequences
clearly these systems have consequences
which affect certain groups in a
negative way but
how do you then address that problem
by a cancer by being hyper Vigilant to
to look for that and also open to
anytime somebody does come and say
hey we think there's a problem over here
like anytime we find a disparity we need
to go examine that carefully so if we
find that groups are are disparate in
their representation somewhere it has to
be examined very carefully if somebody
comes and complains hey that the soap
washing machine is not working for me
let's not dismiss that right so in other
words be inclusive
hyper hyper inclusive of all feedback oh
really it's not working let's figure out
why there's a correlation here people
with dark skin it's not working
uh-oh I'd like to I'd like to briefly
shout out to a girl I had the pleasure
of meeting in Brisbane her name's Loren
legacick she's a diversity consultant
and at first you might think oh is this
there is a bit of a stigma around
people that claim this sort of stuff but
she is the real deal why because she
focuses on she doesn't focus on minor
hypothetical problems and just
nitpicking what she does is she focuses
on things that are really major really
large impact stuff that get completely
overlooked like colorblind the support
for your website or visually impaired
support for apps right these are things
that uh affect a huge number of people
and it boggles the mind how often
companies don't even consider that sort
of stuff there will be people that go
out there and say it's all deliberate
but really the the problem with the
power argument is that doesn't require
humans to reproduce itself it just
that's right you know the these problems
reinforce themselves over time and so we
need to be aware of of the impacts of
this system of the voices that we're not
necessarily hearing and to really go and
seek them out and again like this rolls
back to the inclusivity argument there
is is still this problem of how much
effort do we invest like what's our bang
for buck here given that we don't
necessarily have unlimited resources but
there's so much easy stuff that if
people are just made aware of the basic
stuff and this is where things like the
Montreal aifx Institute like some of the
blogs that you guys have been putting
out this year have been really good at
just flagging this stuff so that people
don't need to go out and discover this
stuff for themselves
yeah I know and I I appreciate the shout
out there to your point around when
we're thinking about okay things like
colorblinder support or all of these
things there I'm not saying they're
simple to implement but they're for for
the most part things that we figured out
how to do and it should be as you said
it's just making people aware of that
and I think it's it's also if you look
at Microsoft Microsoft has a ton of
great support for accessibility features
right there's built into each of the
applications makes it to Keith's point
from earlier it's just you got to make
it that simple and frictionless for
people to just do it right where it's
like oh so you need captions for your
videos oh here's a convenient button
let's just enable captions and it'll
whatever transcript it create the
captions and throw them up on the screen
or whatever that that's what we need and
and that's where I think it's it's just
a matter of getting people to realize
that
being inclusive is not burdensome it's
it it should be something it's let me
put it this way it should be the norm
rather than the exception and again
bringing up Keith's point if we make it
easy if we make it frictionless uh
people have shown a propensity to
actually put that into practice uh yeah
because people generally like to do the
right thing right that's right and so
it's about making the right thing easy
to do so just to continue with Abby's
point and specifically on the color
blindness so believe it or not like
color science for various reasons happen
to be happens to be a hobby of mine or
it was for a long time
and I cared a lot actually about making
my graphs and things like that
accessible to people with various forms
of colorblindness because there actually
turns out there's more than more than
one way in which you can be colorblind
so I learned about like the scilab color
space and how I can choose colors that
have contrast on Dimensions that
colorblind people were likely to see and
that was the the scales I used for my
heat maps and like all that kind of
stuff however even though I put effort
into it and even though I went far
beyond what a normal person would do to
try and Achieve that right fast forward
for some years it's still it's not going
to be easy for me to incorporate that
knowledge I'm going to have to create
custom templates and all kinds of stuff
so this is where like Ai and just better
tooling better software can make the
world such a better place is by making
it automatic or very easy to have
accessible documents and I'd love to see
more investment in that and to the point
that was made earlier about where's
what's our bang for the buck here this
is one of those things where we have to
err on the side of hyper inclusivity
even if it cost us as a civilization a
little bit more to implement
um it's it's it's paid back and all
kinds of you know ways that we really
can't even predict
the thing that concerns me a tiny bit
though is that we're talking about
things that no one would possibly
disagree on
we're talking about fairness of
especially if consumption of services
and and so on let me give another
example let's imagine that we were
building an algorithm to hire Pilots
and it's super important for Pilots to
be able to memorize a certain number of
things in their head and also not to be
colorblind they need to see the color
green so what we do is we come up with
an algorithm to predict
competency for flying and we get them to
do some tests to test their memory and
to test their their color vision and it
just so happens in this imaginary world
that all of the people called David have
an impaired memory and they can't see
the color green and the Machine learning
algorithm learns that and it then
predicts basically that there's a
relationship between being called David
and not being competent to fly
we put this machine learning model into
production and now we don't hire anyone
called David is that a moral aberration
the spurious correlation that it found
that David's
in the sample all happen to be in my
opinion
that's wrong you know that's a sort of
it's a moral a moral problem we should
look out and try to eliminate those
kinds of things but doing it's not so
easy because with neural networks or
whatever who knows like what the heck
the thing is learning right from the
data set and that's where we've got to
do a tremendous amount more work
investing and understanding how to
produce data sets and algorithms that
are more robust for these kinds of
things and we need as a community to get
together and have a crowdsourced
database of kind of correlations that we
don't like so we don't like when they
name is correlated to job outcome so for
example
if in the black community in the United
States certain names are more prevalent
than they are in the White Community
it's wrong if a neural network learns
that maybe these these names shouldn't
be hired or something that's that's
wrong right so we but we need to come
together as a crowd to decide what's
right and wrong in those correlations
because some of them May use a dimension
that we're trying to be careful on say
gender but for very good purposes like
you know detecting breast cancer super
high correlation with gender okay uh
certain diseases super high correlation
with ethnicity right we need to allow
those and the only way to do that is
with some database where we all get
together and contribute Abby's probably
done some extensive work in this area
what's the current like
not so much the state of the art but
what's the agreed upon solution here
like how what's the best practice if
people are encountering these problems
how should they handle it
so I think it's interesting in the sense
that a lot of the problems as your kids
said it's hard to figure out what those
various correlations are and I want to
bring it back to the point that he made
around being inclusive of feedback what
I want to add there is when we're
thinking about best practices there I
think even having a mechanism to collect
that feedback in the first place
where are those mechanisms right where
are those mechanics if I find let's say
the the example that building off of
Tim's example that if I was David and I
got selected how do I provide feedback
on that how do I do it so on that note
uh there was this extension that was
created by Mozilla it's called Uh
regrets reporter I believe or I might be
butchering the name uh but I think it's
something along those lines regret
something essentially it helps you point
out your bad encounters on YouTube and
report them because we need that we need
stuff like that where if we're talking
about inclusion it goes back to my point
about actually empowering people to to
provide feedback to give them the
ability to act and that's where a lot of
these mechanisms fall apart because if
we're talking about oh there's these
stories correlations there's bias in the
data set let me the developer the data
scientist I'll come up with something
that doesn't have bias and I'll fix it
but that's the wrong way to go about it
like you're one piece of the puzzle the
other piece of the puzzle the person
who's affected
should have a mechanism to provide that
feedback to you and and most of the
cases like I and unless you guys know of
other examples I don't actually know of
that many that actually give you the
opportunity to provide feedback where
you can that's a really good point yeah
well maybe this crowdsourcing thing can
help with that it's hot enough to even
get feedback a decision say you're
applying for a credit card I actually I
think they're starting to introduce laws
now but like your insurance premium how
is my insurance premium calculated oh
big random Forest spat out a number and
we we based your your premiums off that
you don't get to see the contributions
half the time the people that are
reading like the partial dependency
plots don't even understand them yeah so
maybe the first steps like any machine
learning derived answer with any sort of
like you should be able to go to the
company and say why was this decision
made I'll take that a step further and
say the company should just if yeah
companies are making so socially
important decisions their mechanisms
should be published openly like
literally here in this GitHub is the
code for the currently trained neural
network that we're using because then
the entire population can examine it and
comment on it but just on that we've
done a show about explainability
recently and machine learning algorithms
are not explainable I understand even if
you published the neural network it
would it doesn't matter no one would
understand it but don't underestimate
the capability of somebody to say hey
look I did this test with this neural
network and everybody that went to this
High School is being rejected for some
reason right so at least we know and we
can we have a shot at resolving that I
know it's not easy but the only sort of
way forward I think is to open it up 100
but but even if you did
because as machine learning models get
more complicated they are less
explainable and some of the more
sophisticated Transformers models for
example they are not explainable and
never will pick but if you make it
really simple and you have a rules-based
system and and the banks do that this is
the law by the way that they have to
tell you exactly why you didn't get a
credit card then you could game it
because you could say oh that was 15 it
should have been 14 I'm going to make it
14. so it doesn't really help you either
no hey if debt to income ratio should be
something and you work hard to lower it
what's the problem maybe it's not all
bad if people quote unquote game it but
that's a feedback loop
look so if for example to get a certain
job I want I need to have some
certifications is it bad that I go get
those certifications yeah but this is
the thing we were talking about last
time that when you have objective
Obsession and you optimize on the
objectives then you just create perverse
incentives and shortcuts and you destroy
the whole system it's not black and
white though so that's what I tried to
argue back then is it isn't this false
dilemma black white bad good again if I
need three different certifications to
increase my chance of getting hired for
a job by 10 and I work hard and go get
those certifications that's great
that's not a bad thing
I want to let Abby comment on this
because I've got another question
no so the the point that I wanted to
make was so it's something of what Kim
just said that it it isn't a dichotomy
right so there are Shades of Gray in
there in the sense that
I I agree with Tim that a lot of this
stuff is just inherently just not
understandable for a human being and
human beings also is not understandable
to people who actually work in machine
learning less so for people who don't
right who are computer scientists and
even less so for people who are not in
computer science whatsoever so there's
that
but
where I think Keith's point is important
is that you can have this sort of
testing and poking and that I think is a
valuable activity to give you an example
the uh and and I'm sure you guys came
across this as well the Twitter uh the
cropping of the pictures right where
they where they did a bunch of like
poking the holes in itself what kind of
uh characteristics is it prioritizing in
terms of which portion of the image gets
uh sort of dropped or or not based on
skin tone based on gender based on so
many different things and they did a
little bit of documentation around it
right so it's almost this notion of
adversarially trying to test and see how
you can break the system and encouraging
that behavior and and enabling that
behavior by making that public so that I
think is the value to what Keith is
saying and in in fact it just came out I
think last week where the Netherlands I
believe has published an algorithm
registry where they're trying to capture
the the details of different algorithmic
systems in a publicly accessible
registry
I know I haven't actually taken a look
at what the details of that are but I
would assume that it would facilitate
the kind of mechanisms that keep us is
talking about the other thing that I
wanted to and I'll turn that back to you
then because I know you had something to
say there but one of the things that I
found problematic when we're talking
about all these incorporating feedback
and when Alex was saying let's say you
had some credit decision about you and
something went wrong and it's oh this is
a random forest model whatever and then
they say okay you know what we're gonna
do we're going to put a human in the
loop because people love that and so we
here's a human in the loop so now we're
off the hook now we're off the hook well
we're not you know why because a human
in the loop
is not useful until they have meaningful
control if you're just a token human
then that's the Air France flight case
where it was the flight handed over
control and so yeah you still have a
human in the loop The Ellen is still
sitting there except the pilot and
atrophied their skills to the point
where they didn't know what the signs
were and they they just continued to
think they were going up and they were
you know you know crashing down they
were they were stalling right and it's
okay you're a human in the loop is only
useful if they have meaningful agency
which in a lot of cases doesn't happen
and by agency I'd also you mean
competence there were lots of we were
talking about the algo shambles in the
UK when they the teachers predicted the
grades and people just assumed that
because it was uh in meat space it was
humans doing it then it was all okay and
right yeah with algorithms as well of
course there's a difference between
understandability and transparency you
can publish the neural network people
won't understand how it works of course
but just across your brain you can't
publish that's why I made the point
there about we have to consider what the
alternative is right it's if I'm
choosing between a self-driving truck
that has an accident rate of whatever uh
one every 100 000 miles versus a a
human-driven truck that's rate of 10
times that yeah there's a thought
experiment would you rather fly on a
plane which has been rigorously tested
but you didn't understand how it worked
or the other way around yeah I think we
all know what what the decision would be
so testing is super important and you
don't need to understand the system to
test it and that's why of course I
advocate for ML devops and as far as I'm
concerned the most important part is
from after the data scientist has
finished validating the model
interactively it's a non-interactive
orchestration of model behavioral tests
doing things like counterfactual
examples and a whole bunch of a battery
of tests to try and break the model
because this is the way that that we
actually operate in an engineering
setting
I want to bring it back to one thing
about the the colorblind Pilots because
I forgot to mention that there's an
alternative here right which is to spend
a little bit of extra money to make it
flyable by people that have color
blindness right so so you know if we're
talking about whatever the 80 million
dollar F-35 okay if it costs an extra
100 per airplane to have a a mode that a
pilot can fly in where they're just as
effective if they're colorblind that's
an even better solution than just not
hiring them on that because you've
personified this this um inclusion
argument because you're making the N
plus one argument because if we could
spend that amount of money why not spend
more if you give 20 of your money to
charity why not 21 why not 22 percent
yeah except we're talking about there's
a finite pool of kind of uh a finite
pool to the inclusion So eventually we
get to the point where there's a risk
reward or inclusion versus reward
profile right so I'm not saying if it
costs an extra 10 million dollars per
plane that we do it what I'm saying is
we evaluate that trade-off and err on
the side of inclusion to some degree and
then leave it up to the courts to decide
whether that was sufficient sure but it
would still converge somewhere and the
exact nature of that convergence is a
point to be discussed but Abby was
saying before that there was something
called Ranger I think where on YouTube
you can flag content which you think
isn't inclusive or that you didn't like
other if I've understood that correctly
but it's a little bit like not offending
people now you can't give a speech to
more than let's say 100 people because
it only takes one person to say that I'm
offended by that and of course language
is conflated with violence now it's
quite serious so it's the same thing
with with inclusion that every time you
include one person you exclude another
person so it's not super clear where you
draw the line here
yeah I'm not sure I don't think that
holds every time I include someone I
exclude someone like I can think of lots
of cases where that doesn't hold yeah if
I have a part so I'm gonna have a party
this weekend four people are invited now
I include a fifth one I didn't exclude
anybody what if you've only got a
capacity of five people but now we're
adding greater conditions to it in other
words suppose I've got 10 positions I
need to fill and I bring in a candidate
pool of 50 white people
and then I actually decide I need to be
more inclusive and I bring in a
candidate pool of 60 people like 50
white and 10 black because that's what
the population is or whatever I'm still
only going to hire 10 people but I've
included the entire group and the
opportunity for that job and that's
what's that's what's important here is
the opportunity right without that kind
of bias to your color or your ethnicity
or whatnot so I don't think I'm I'm
excluding anyone I think I'm only
broadening out
the inclusivity for the opportunity to
everyone and certainly in the case of
the party that was just a direct Edition
to your point keep so the example that
you gave which was so you started so you
had 10 positions to fill right and you
had 50 people who who are all white
and and then the you realize that while
you were being you weren't being
inclusive so we went out and expanded
the the potential candidate pool to be
now 50 uh white people and and 10 black
people that's it so we're now at 60
people over the number of spots is still
10. so I'm just thinking now in terms of
Tim's Point around exclusion in a sense
the the the probability of of being
selected has gone down for each of the
people what might because there is a
constraint there right like had you
boosted the number of Physicians by two
as well maybe then we we now actually
continue to maintain the percentage
probability for each of the people but
you're also being inclusive in terms of
bringing in uh a more diverse pool of
candidates except I understand of course
you might have resource constraints and
you can only hire 10 people and not hire
12 people in the first place
yeah but that I've included a hundred
percent of the demographics in the
opportunity for that role so there's
different sort of rings of inclusion I'm
just saying in some rings of the
inclusion if you will or some layers
including people doesn't exclude them
so it's not always the case that
including another person absolutely
excludes someone else like including or
if you do include someone maybe the cost
is shared by all and then it's fair so
if we're having conversation
okay and and we let's say we have four
people here now we brought in a fifth
person if we were being inclusive and
they took up one-fifth of the air time
we've all equally shared in that yeah
yeah 100 percent
so just because I'm aware that we're
running short on time I'm gonna fire a
question at Abby now
I actually became aware of Abby a very
long time ago I didn't realize it until
I was like doing some research for this
video I'm like hang on I've seen this
video before because Abby was one of
like uh
this kind of wave of voices around 2018
I think it was beginning in 2018.
everyone's talking about AI is Doom and
Gloom or it's the Silicon Valley AI
Utopia and here's this guy that's
talking in sensible terms about both the
challenges and the opportunities of AI
surprisingly like I'm a fan however I
also found out that you guys had a hand
in the ethics statements that appear in
a lot of papers these days a lot of AI
papers I believe it was it was at least
the Montreal AI ethics Institute that
co-authored the recommendations that
kind of went off in Europe's and all
that sort of thing and kind of led to
this tact-on section at the end of
papers
that doesn't ever quite work like it's
clear the intent is to get people to
Think Through the consequences of their
algorithms
but these people aren't trained
ethicists I given that there are more
effective Alternatives out there things
like fiction
things like things like practical
scenarios that actually will force like
will naturally induce people to think
through these situations
is there a motivation is there a
justification for a section like this
which largely on reading seems to be
just a a tick in the Box exercise does
this actually do anything to promote
ethics in AI just a quick extension to
that so this is the so-called broader
impact statement which is being around
for a while now because Janet quite
often jokes about this at the end of his
videos that they are largely copy pasted
and you can just change a few words so
usually if it's a computer vision paper
there's a bit of blah blah blah about
how this could potentially discriminate
against people and so on and it's become
a box ticking exercise but this is
really interesting because at work as
well I'm involved in AI governance and
one of the big challenges we have is to
get people to think consequentially and
of course there's a limit to that
because you a lot of people don't really
want to think consequently and even if
they could there are unintended
consequences and so on but what's your
response to Alex's question
no that's a great question I mean I
think to the point of the relevance of
broader impact statements I think there
is all the points in terms of criticisms
are valid I think it's the first step in
the sense that it at least
forces people to think about it even if
even for a second if even for a second I
know that of course as everybody rushes
through the cycle of neurons and icml
and I clear and then round you go again
if you're submitting your paper five
minutes before the deadline you're just
gonna copy and paste the ethics
statement to to just meet the deadline
and that's a problem with any uh sort of
attack on addition that you do that it
has the potential to morph into a box
sticking exercise which is what I think
the problem is with something like this
as well
the concern I I would say or the or the
thing that I would say here is that at
least it makes something for a second
which hopefully over time sets a
precedent where if we were to come up
with more owners requirements we would
we would have a precedent that gets said
that hey this is something that we need
to do now again I'm with you on the fact
that neither of these people lattices
and these are the people who are
actually going to be the ones who are
going to be reviewing the ethic
statements as on the other side because
when you sign up as an author you're
also signing up to be a reviewer and to
a large extent it's just uh let's call
it a visual cycle because but my hope is
that it can turn into a virtuous cycle
where there are possibly enough number
of actors just through a random
allotment let's say who would point out
some ethical concerns so let's say your
paper was to come to me I certainly
would take a critical look at that and
I'm hoping that there are more and more
people such as all of us here on this
call who if we were asked to review a
paper would carefully look at that
statement and the fact that it is there
we now have grounds to reject the paper
potentially based on that which before
you didn't have an option because it
wasn't even there so what would I say
and maybe it won't even be front and
center of my mind in the first place
because it wasn't included as a part of
this Mission so again these are all
post-hoc justifications in terms of
addressing the criticisms but I think
it's at least a a tiny step in the right
direction and hopefully leads to more
meaningful steps there one of the
problems I have though with technology
governance because it's a similar thing
that I deal with in my job is technology
is meta it's abstract it's the way it's
applied that's where it's quite easy to
to bring in ethical principles and so on
because you might make the argument that
technology is morally neutral and a lot
of scientists resent having to think
about how their technology might be
applied because anything could be
applied for nefarious purposes yeah so
it's almost like we're applying this at
the wrong level
um
I think part of the challenge too is
they're not trained like scientists
aren't trained to be philosophers
and a lot of ethical like beyond the
obvious stuff a lot of ethical things
like epistemic harm epistemic harm is a
phenomena I find fascinating but
outside of dedicated Educators and
people that have spoken to Dedicated
educators
most people are probably never going to
be in a position to even consider such a
thing
but there's also this thing that there's
technology people in process and you
need all of those things and in my
opinion technology is fairly agnostic in
in a company when if you're a Google for
example you should have a very strong
application governance process you
should have check-ins through the life
cycle even at Inception of every project
what model do I use how do I do the
metric selection how am I validating
this model how am I productionizing how
might it be used what are the negative
consequences all of this stuff happens
at the application Level it can't happen
at the technology level yeah 100 and
it's easy to complain but it's much
harder to do something and seeing the
ethical statement as a step in the right
direction that's fair enough
I have to drive gentlemen but it was a
pleasure to speak with you all
yeah likewise likewise skip
bye-bye yeah it's been an amazing show
thank you so much guys anyway we've come
up to time Abby this has been an
absolute honor having you on the show I
really appreciate it it's been amazing
hey like
wise I really appreciate the opportunity
I think we've got to cover so much
ground and and I yeah I think the format
is fantastic thank you so much for
inviting me Abby thank you so much it's
been an absolutely honor thank you I
really appreciate it
hey it's my pleasure I really appreciate
it amazing cool take care guys and have
a great weekend
see you later bye